you are famously tweeted it looks like
if you bombard Earth with photons for a
while you can emit A roadster
so if like an Hitchhiker's Guide to the
Galaxy we would summarize the story of
Earth so in in that book it's mostly
harmless
uh what do you think is all the possible
stories like a paragraph long or a
sentence long
that Earth could be summarized as once
it's done it's computation so like all
the Possible full
if Earth is a book right yeah uh
probably there has to be an ending I
mean there's going to be an end to Earth
and it could end in all kinds of ways
you can end soon it can end later what
do you think are the possible stories
well definitely there seems to be
yeah you're sort of
it's pretty incredible that these
self-replicating systems will basically
arise from the Dynamics and then they
perpetuate themselves and become more
complex and eventually become conscious
and build a society and I kind of feel
like in some sense it's kind of like a
deterministic wave uh that you know that
kind of just like happens on any you
know any sufficiently well arranged
system like Earth
and so I kind of feel like there's a
certain sense of inevitability in it
um and it's really beautiful and it ends
somehow right so it's a it's a
chemically
a diverse environment
where complex dynamical systems can
uh evolve and become more more further
and further complex but then there's a
certain
um
what is it there's certain terminating
conditions
yeah I don't know what the terminating
conditions are but definitely there's a
trend line of something and we're part
of that story and like where does that
where does it go so you know we're
famously described often as a biological
Bootloader for AIS and that's because
humans I mean you know we're an
incredible
uh biological system and we're capable
of computation and uh you know and love
and so on
um but we're extremely inefficient as
well like we're talking to each other
through audio it's just kind of
embarrassing honestly they were
manipulating like seven symbols uh
serially we're using vocal cords it's
all happening over like multiple seconds
yeah it's just like kind of embarrassing
when you step down to the
uh frequencies at which computers
operate or are able to cooperate on and
so basically it does seem like
um synthetic intelligences are kind of
like the next stage of development and
um I don't know where it leads to like
at some point I suspect uh the universe
is some kind of a puzzle
and these synthetic AIS will uncover
that puzzle and um solve it
and then what happens after right like
what because if you just like Fast
Forward Earth many billions of years
it's like uh it's quiet and then it's
like tomorrow you see like city lights
and stuff like that and then what
happens at like at the end like is it
like a
is it or is it like uh calming is it
explosion is it like Earth like open
like a giant because you said
emit Roasters let's start emitting like
like a giant number of Like Satellites
yes to some kind of a crazy explosion
and we're living we're like we're
stepping through a explosion and we're
like living day to day and it doesn't
look like it but it's actually if you I
saw a very cool animation of Earth uh
and life on Earth and basically nothing
happens for a long time and then the
last like two seconds like basically
cities and everything and just in the
low earth orbit just gets cluttered and
just the whole thing happens in the last
few seconds and you're like this is
exploding this is a statement explosion
so if you play
yeah yeah if you play it at normal speed
yeah is it'll just look like an
explosion it's a firecracker we're
living in a firecracker where it's going
to start emitting all kinds of
interesting things yeah and then so
explosion doesn't it might actually look
like a little explosion with with lights
and fire and energy emitted all that
kind of stuff but when you look inside
the details of the explosion there's
actual complexity happening where
there's like uh yeah human life or some
kind of life we hope it's another
destructive firecracker it's kind of
like a constructive
firecracker all right so given that I
think uh hilarious disgusting it is a
really interesting to think about like
what the puzzle of the universe is that
the creator of the universe uh give us a
message like for example in the book
contact
UM Carl Sagan uh there's a message for
Humanity for any civilization in uh
digits in the expansion of Pi in base 11
eventually which is kind of interesting
thought uh maybe maybe we're supposed to
be giving a message to our creator maybe
we're supposed to somehow create some
kind of a quantum mechanical system that
alerts them to our intelligent presence
here because if you think about it from
their perspective it's just say like
Quantum field Theory massive like
cellular automaton like thing and like
how do you even notice that we exist you
might not even be able to pick us up in
that simulation and so how do you uh how
do you prove that you exist that you're
intelligent and that you're a part of
the universe so this is like a touring
test for intelligence from Earth yeah
the Creator is uh I mean maybe this is
uh like trying to complete the next word
in a sentence this is a complicated way
of that like Earth is just is basically
sending a message back yeah the puzzle
is basically like alerting the Creator
that we exist or maybe the puzzle is
just to just break out of the system and
just uh you know stick it to the Creator
in some way uh basically like if you're
playing a video game you can um
you can somehow find an exploit and find
a way to execute on the host machine in
the arbitrary code there's some for
example I believe someone got a Mario a
game of Mario to play Pong just by uh
exploiting it and then
um creating a basically writing writing
code and being able to execute arbitrary
code in the game and so maybe we should
be maybe that's the puzzle isn't that we
should be um
uh find a way to exploit it so so I
think like some of these synthetic AIS
will eventually find the universe to be
some kind of a puzzle and then solve it
in some way and that's kind of like the
end game somehow do you often think
about it as a as a simulation so as the
universe being a kind of computation
that has might have bugs and exploits
yes yeah I think so is that what physics
is essentially I think it's possible
that physics has exploits and we should
be trying to find them arranging some
kind of a crazy quantum mechanical
system that somehow gives you buffer
overflow somehow gives you a rounding
error and a floating Point
uh uh yeah that's right and like more
and more sophisticated exploits like
those are jokes but that could be
actually very close yeah we'll find some
way to extract infinite energy for
example when you train a reinforcement
learning agents um in physical
simulations and you ask them to say run
quickly on the flat ground they'll end
up doing all kinds of like weird things
um in part of that optimization right
they'll get on their back leg and they
will slide across the the floor and it's
because of the optimization the
enforcement learning optimization on
that agent has figured out a way to
extract infinite energy from the
friction forces and basically their poor
implementation and they found a way to
generate infinite energy and just slide
across the surface and it's not what you
expected it's just a it's sort of like a
perverse solution and so maybe we can
find something like that maybe we can be
that little
dog in this physical simulation the the
cracks or escapes the intended
consequences of the physics that the
Universe came up with we'll figure out
some kind of shortcut to some weirdness
yeah and then oh man but see the problem
with that weirdness is the first person
to discover the weirdness like sliding
in the back legs that's all we're going
to do yeah it's very quickly because
everybody does that thing so like the
the paperclip maximizer is a ridiculous
idea but that very well yeah could be
what then we'll just uh we'll just all
switch that because it's so fun well no
person will Discover it I think by the
way I think it's going to have to be uh
some kind of a super intelligent AGI of
a third generation
like we're building the first generation
AGI you know
third generation yeah so the the
Bootloader for an AI the that AI yeah
will be a Bootloader for another AI yeah
and then there's no way for us to
introspect like what that might even uh
I think it's very likely that these
things for example like say you have
these agis it's very likely that for
example they will be completely inert I
like these kinds of sci-fi books
sometimes where these things are just
completely inert they don't interact
with anything and I find that kind of
beautiful because uh they probably
they've probably figured out the meta
game of the universe in some way
potentially they're they're doing
something completely beyond our
imagination
um and uh they don't interact with
simple chemical life forms like why
would you do that so I find those kinds
of ideas compelling what's their source
of fun what is it what are they doing
what's the score solving in the universe
but inert so can you define what it
means inert so they escape
as in um
they will behave in some very like
strange way to us because they're uh
they're beyond they're playing the
metagame uh and The Meta game is
probably say like a ranging quantum
mechanical systems in some very weird
ways to extract Infinite Energy uh solve
the digital expansion of Pi to whatever
amount uh they will build their own like
little Fusion reactors or something
crazy like they're doing something
Beyond Comprehension and uh not
understandable to us and actually
brilliant under the hood what if quantum
mechanics itself is the system and we're
just thinking it's physics
but we're really parasites on on or not
parasite we're not really hurting
physics we're just living on this
organisms this organism and we're like
trying to understand it but really it is
an organism and with a deep deep
intelligence maybe physics itself is
uh the the organism that's doing a super
interesting thing and we're just like
one little thing yeah ant sitting on top
of it trying to get energy from it we're
just kind of like these particles in a
wave that I feel like is mostly
deterministic and takes uh Universe from
some kind of a big bang to some kind of
a super intelligent replicator some kind
of a stable point in the universe given
these laws of physics you don't think uh
as Einstein said God doesn't play dice
so you think it's mostly deterministic
there's no Randomness in the thing I
think it's deterministic oh there's tons
of uh well I'm I want to be careful with
Randomness pseudo random yeah I don't
like random uh I think maybe the laws of
physics are deterministic
um yeah I think they're determinants
just got really uncomfortable with the
question
do you have anxiety about whether the
universe is random or not
what's like there's no Randomness uh you
say you like Goodwill Hunting it's not
your fault Andre it's not it's not your
fault man
um so you don't like Randomness uh yeah
I think it's uh unsettling I think it's
a deterministic system I think that
things that look random like say the uh
collapse of the wave function Etc I
think they're actually deterministic
just entanglement uh and so on and uh
some kind of a Multiverse Theory
something something okay so why does it
feel like we have a free will
like if I raise the hand I chose to do
this now um
what
that doesn't feel like a deterministic
thing it feels like I'm making a choice
it feels like it okay so it's all
feelings it's just feelings yeah
so when an RL agent is making a choice
is that
um
it's not really making a choice the
choices are all already there yeah
you're interpreting the choice and
you're creating a narrative for or
having made it yeah and now we're
talking about the narrative it's very
meta